grgrande Russie, cette grande
féfédération de Russie et qui vt
alaller chercher l'Ukraine.
PaPanel un peu chamboulé. On
dedevait parler entre autres des
mamasques. On va prendre le tem,
jeje vous présente Stéphanie
ChChouinard, Michel C Auger et
JoJonathan Trudeau.
ToTour de table sur ce qu'on vit
d'd'entendre. Point de presse
anannonçait la dernièrere mine e
MoMonsieur Trudeau. Après s Joe
BiBiden, ce n'est pas étonnant e
quque le Canada annonce. Présene
mimilitaire accrue, sanction. En
mmêmeme temps, celui qui est pe-
êêtrtre le moins étonné ce soir
c'c'est Vladimir Poutine.
- - Quand quelqu'un décide qu'il
ququitte les normes de la
cocommunauté internationale, qul
ququitte les valeurs des Nations
ununies émanant fait rien qu'à a
ttêtete, il n'y a pas grand-choe
dédéranger beaucoup. Le discours
d'd'hier été surréaliste. Il dit
quque ce pays-là n n'aurait pas
exexisté, mais incidemment Kiev
esest une ville plus vieille que
MoMoscou. Quand quelqu'un refuse
leles normes, ce qui arrive doit
ararriver, les occidentaux avait
prprévu des sanctions.
- - Quand quelqu'un a un plaidor
émémotif comme celui d'hier,
c'c'était tout sauf rationnel,
c'c'est un plaidoyer émotif sure
reretour de la Russie, on a été
babafoué depuis les années 90.
C'C'est ce cocktail qui peut ête
dadangereux. Le Canada, on est
lilimité mais on répond comment
pepeut répondre j'imagine.
- - Je pense que c'est dans
l'l'ordre des choses que le Cana
ememboîtete le pas aux États-Unt
auaux partenaires de l'OTAN. Mas
pepersonne ne pense que le Canaa
vava faire trembler Vladimir
PoPoutine, mais c'est un peu
l'l'aspect moderne des conflits
gégéopolitiques. Il y a des gens
ququi craignent des affrontemens
susur le terrain. Plus on va
avavancer au cours des années ac
lala globalité de l'économie, on
vava davantage assister à d des
guguerres froides perpétuelles u
lala façon de faire le plus malà
l'l'adversaire, ce sera par le
bibiais de sanctions économique.
LeLe Canada s'inscrit dans cette
lilignée ce serait d'avoir jusqà
ququel point Vladimir Poutine aa
unune tolérance élevée. Vous
paparliez d'émotivité, c'est
l'l'aspect qui m'inquiètete. Ont
totout sauf de l'émotivité dans
dedes conflits aussi importants.
- - Cet engrenage est en
momouvement. Difficile de reculr
ququand on avance comme ça.
- - Oui, d'autant plus qu'on pae
dede sanctions économiques qui t
étété imposées par le Canada et
leles alliés, mais il y a eu des
momorts hier. Cinq ukrainiens ot
étété tués par les forces russe,
paparce qu'ils avaient soi-disat
trtraversé la frontièrere et que
c'c'était potentiellement des
sasaboteurs. Très s peu de perss
crcroisaient sur la scènene
ininternationale. En plus du
didiscours surréaliste d'hier
sosoir, on est déjà r rendu
aiailleurs. On est déjà r rendus
unun potentiel qui dépasse les
sasanctions économiques.
- - Est-ce qu'on est équipé en
EuEurope, aux États-Unis et au
CaCanada, pour répondre à c ce e
fafait Poutine actuellement? Ona
l'l'impression qu'on est quand
mmêmeme relativement impuissantn
enenverra pas de cela en Ukrain,
c'c'est sûr.r.
- - Pour ce qui est du Canada, a
viviolence est plutôt t limitée.
QuQuand on regarde les forces de
l'l'union européenne, les États-
UnUnis qui ont un poids importat
dadans la balance et le Canada,e
pepense que c'est la force du
nonombre qui pourrait faire
flflancher Vladimir Poutine. Qud
onon parle par exemple de toutes
leles notions d'énergie,
l'l'Allemagne qui suspend un
prprojet fort important pour les
chchoses, je pense que c'est coe
çaça qu'on va êtrtre capable de
memettre une pression qui sera
pepeut-êtrtre suffisant pour dor
leles intentions de Poutine.
- - Le nerf de la guerre, on pae
dede ce pipeline. C'est de
l'l'argent et ça peut faire mal.
- - Ça peut faire mal. Et la
dedeuxièmeme étape de sanction i
n'n'a pas été commandée encore r
leles occidentaux, c'est de dir:
mamaintenant, vous retirez du
sysystèmeme bancaire internatio.
VoVos cartes de crédit ne
fofonctionneront plus nulle part
etet vous ne pouvez plus emprunr
susur les marchés. Ça peut faire
trtrès s mal. Mais c'est pas le
prpremier jour, Monsieur Poutine
n'n'a pas presque plus de résers
enen argent américain. Il s'est
prpréparé pour ça. Il y a une
lilimite à c ce que les sanctios
momonétaires peuvent faire. À
papartir du moment où Joe Biden
didit qui n'enverra pas de
trtroubles, c'est une grosse
afaffaire qui n'est plus sur la
tatable.
- - Ce gazoduc est extrêmemement
imimportant pour les Allemands t
popour les Russes, qui voulaient
vevendre. C'est quand mêmeme des
grgrosses poignées.
- - Ce qui s'est passé dans les4
dernrnièreres heures, ces
clclarinettes que c'est la
dédécision de l'allemand qui fat
lele plus mal de toutes les
sasanctions imposées jusqu'à
mamaintenant. Entre-temps, entre
cece que Michel vient de
mementionner ce qui a été annoné
jujusqu'à m maintenant, il y avt
l'l'option mitoyenne d'imposer
dadans les deux régions de Donek
etet le GAN, l'imposait la Russe
auau complet, imposé aux Canadis
dede ne plus investir dans quele
dodomaine que ce soit dans
l'l'économie russe. C'est
seseulement le Canada qui prend
cecette direction, ça va êtrtre
lilimité, mais c'est ça se fait
d'd'un commun accord avec tous s
alalliés de l'OTAN, ça pourrait
avavoir un impact.
- - On revient chez nous. Le
mamasque l'école, s'est terminée
lele 7 mars au Québec. Écoutante
dédébat sur les mesures d'urgene
auau Québec. L'opposition demane
àà M Monsieur Legault de lever
l'l'état d'urgence qui donne du
popouvoir au gouvernement.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - J'ai l'impression que
lele premier ministre veut
lele beurre et l'argent du beur.
C'C'est-à-d-dire qu'il nous dit:
"J"Je ne veux plus faire de
popoint de presse de gestion
dede crise parce qu'on n'est
plplus en état de crise."
BiBien, dans ce cas-là, , qu'one
l'l'état d'urgence sanitaire.
LeLe premier ministre veut
cocontinuer à g gouverner seul
papar décret, mais plus à a avor
àà r répondre à d des questions
emembêtatantes des journalistes.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Aujourd'hui, au Québec,
ilil y a personne qui pense
ququ'on est en urgence sanitair.
IlIl y a personne qui pense
ququ'on devrait arrêteter
lala démocratie, en fait,
onon devrait la faire fonctionn.
C'C'est la responsabilité du
prpremier ministre.
- - Est-ce que le Parti libéral
esest d'accord pour payer
dedes primes aux infirmièreres?.
EsEst-ce que le Parti libéral
esest d'accord pour garder
lele passeport vaccinal pendant
enencore quelques semaines? Oui.
EsEst-ce que le Parti libéral
esest d'accord pour qu'on embaue
dedes gens qui ont peut-êtrtre s
leles mêmemes qualifications
ququi étaient prévues dans
lala convention collective
popour vacciner? Le Parti libérl
esest d'accord.
P Pour êtrtre capable de faire
totout ça, on a besoin de
l'l'urgence sanitaire.
- - Le gouvernement plaide qu'ia
enencore besoin de l'état
d'd'urgence. A-t-il été efficace
dadans son plaidoyer?
- - Je pense qu'il répètete tous
lele mêmeme message. Celle répèe
l'l'urgence sanitaire, c'est por
dedes raisons bien précises, coe
leles primes aux infirmièreres u
imimposer le port du masque dans
cecertains endroits. Les gens
pepeuvent comprendre qu'il y a
pepeut-êtrtre encore une certaie
nénécessité. Je me questionne sr
l'l'insistance des partis
d'd'opposition à t toujours ramr
cece concept qui est un peu
ababstrait. Les Québécois qui ns
écécoutent depuis quelque tempse
plplus en plus incapable de sorr
dede la maison et vaquer à l les
ococcupations. Il n'y a pas
d'd'urgence sanitaire qu'il
apappelle sur les épaules chaque
jojour lorsqu'il se lèveve. On a
l'l'impression d'entendre le mêe
memessage qu'on a entendu avanta
cicinquièmeme vague.
- - C'est plus une question de
cocommodité pour le gouvernemen.
IlIl pourrait continuer à d donr
dedes primes aux infirmièreres l
n'n'y avait pas d'urgence
sasanitaire. L'Ontario s'en est
papassé et la Colombie-Britannie
auaussi. Mais c'est facile, c'et
cocommode et M. Legault à u une
grgrosse majorité alors pourquoi
s's'en priver. C'est vraiment de
lala commodité plutôt t que de
l'l'obligation.
- - On regarde ça de l'Ontario t
onon se dit qu'il y a certainemt
unune autre façon de gérer la
chchose. Les partis d'opposition
poposent des questions quant à a
fifin du gouvernement par décre,
cece sont des questions
imimportantes qui sont peut-être
ababstraites, mais il faut quand
mmêmeme voir que ça fait plus de
10100 jours que l'opposition ne
pepeut pas faire son travail das
l'l'assemblée législative. C'est
lele genre sanitaire est termin,
ququ'on en revienne à d des débs
cocomme ça devrait êtrtre le cas
d'd'habitude.
- - Le masque, on devait en parr
plplus tôt.t. En revenant de cos
scscolaires, il n'y a pas grand
momonde qui va s'opposer à ç ça.
- - Je ne pense pas, surtout
ququ'ils vont garder le masque
dadans les aires communes. C'est
dadans les classes qu'on va le
reretirer. Le dernier endroit ùu
onon va garder les masques, ce
sosont les accommodés et collere
trtransport en commun. C'est le
dédébut de la fin du mal, mais e
n'n'est pas la fin du masque.
- - La façon avec laquelle on a
prprocédé pour faire cette annoe
llà, , on vient démontrer que le
gogouvernement souhaite se
reretourner d'une gestion au
ququotidien de la pandémie.
FrFrançois Legault petit à p pet
n'n'assistait plus nécessaireme.
DeDe presse du ministre de la
sasanté. On a annoncé le retrait
d'd'une mesure qui était
sisignificative par voie de
cocommuniqué. Le gouvernement vt
trtranquillement s'effacer,
dédéprogrammer la population qui
ététait rendue dépendante de ses
ininterventions hebdomadaires et
dédémontrer qu'on s'en va
grgraduellement vers autre chos.
- - On ne veut plus faire...
popolitiquement, c'est clair que
lele gouvernement Legault veut e
reretirer de ce qui était perçu
cocomme étant l'interface publie
dede toutes les décisions. On vt
lalaisser au Docteur Boileau
mamaintenant le soin de faire ds
popoints de presse.
- - On voit que le gouvernement
esest de moins en moins présent
susur la place publique pour
jujustifier certaines des
dédécisions qui sont prises. Ce
seserait intéressant de voir en
OnOntario si on fait la danse à
dedeux depuis le début de la
papandémie, c'est-à-d-dire si Dg
FoFord va décider de suivre le
gogouvernement du Québec en ce i
a a trop masque dans les écoles.
C'C'est quelque chose qu'on
susurveille.
- - Jean Charest va-t-il se
lalancer? Christian Noël, vous
avavez fait un texte ce matin.
VoVous allez plus loin que
d'd'autres en disant : il veut,n
pepeut s'entendre qu'il veut, ms
ilil se prépare activement. Les
apappuis s'accumulent. Ce n'est
papas du tout le mêmeme film quy
a a deux ans.
- - Pas du tout, Monsieur Sherrt
a a davantage l'impression qu'il
rereçoit plus d'appui. Deux
ququestions : est-ce qu'il veut?
LaLa réponse semble êtrtre oui.a
dedeuxièmeme question est est-ce
ququ'il peut gagner. Et là, , il
atattend quelles vont êtrtre les
rrèglgles à l la course. Il peut
enencore changer d'idée. On avat
enentendu jusqu'à l la dernièree
miminute et finalement ça avait
étété un nom en 2020, pour
reremplacer Andrew Scheer.
PoPoilievre qui est maintenant
cacandidat se préparé à f fairen
anannoncé l'avait réservé une
sasalle communautaire dans sa
cicirconscription et laver, on
nonous avait dit que c'était
anannulé. Jean Charest est encoe
lala possibilité d'annuler, mais
ilil veut. L'alerte publiée dans
leles journaux ce matin avec
plplusieurs députés membres du
PaParti conservateur de plusieus
prprovinces différentes, c'est n
pepeu pour flatter l'ego de
MoMonsieur Sherret et créer un
momomentum pour lui dire qu'on i
dédéroule tapis rouge. Comment a
pepersonne qui a été choisie por
êêtrtre le sauveur du Parti libl
auau Québec peut résister à u un
apappel pour êtrtre le sauveur u
PaParti conservateur auCanada?
C'C'est un peu pour ça que M.
ReReyes avaient plein de bonnes
chchoses à d dire sur lui.
ALALAIN RAYES, député PCC
RiRichmond-Arthabaska, Qc
- - C'est clair, je serais plus
heheureux s'il avait dit oui,
mamais je vous confirme que non,
sasa réflexion avance, cependan.
CeCe serait malhonnêtete de vous
didire que je ne lui parle pas.
JeJe lui parle. Mais je pense qe
c'c'est une grande réflexion
popour lui, pour sa famille.
JeJe peux comprendre qu'il veuie
pepeser le pour et le contre,
prprendre le temps de faire
lala bonne réflexion.
MaMais ultimement, s'il décide e
sese lancer, il aura des soldats
cocomme moi qui seront à s ses s
popour pouvoir livrer bataille,
gagagner la course à l la cheff,
pupuis après s ça, gagner le rôe
dede premier ministre du Canada.
- - Jonathan, il a le goût,t, ct
dadans son ADN. Est-ce que les
coconditions cette fois-ci sont
réréunies pour qu'il y aille?
- - J'ai l'impression que de pls
enen plus, les conditions sont
réréunies et les signaux
dédémontrent qu'il est favorabl,
ququ'il a envie de faire le sau.
IlIl coche plusieurs cas en ce
momoment. L'appui des membres du
cacaucus conservateur du Québec,
çaça a beaucoup d'influence. Au
niniveau organisationnel, il y a
dedes militants en place, entre
auautres des militants libéraux
prprovinciaux désabusés qui ont
enenvie de se lancer. Prévoit ls
rrèglgles de la course. La lette
dede ce matin, je ne pense pas e
c'c'était nécessairement pour
coconvaincre Monsieur ajamais pr
fafaire contrepoids à l la tonaé
nénégatif qu'on entend Québec.
CeCertaines du passif de Jean
ChCharest mais il y a des gens i
veveulent dire qu'il n'y a pas e
dedes négatifs.
- - Il n'y a pas d'appui dans ls
tetests, dans l'ouest pardon das
cecette lettre. C'est important
ququ'il ne soit pas perçu commee
cacandidat du caucus du Québec n
plplus.
- - Ça, ça pourrait lui nuire le
jojour du vote par ce que la
dedernièrere fois, il y a eu un
chchangement dans les règlglemes
auau sein du parti conservateur.
DaDans une circonscription, s'il
n'n'y a pas 100 membres, la
cicirconscription ne comptera ps
sasans poioint. Il y aura du trl
popour l'équipe de pour s'assurr
quque toutes les circonscriptios
vovont valoir la totalité des
popoints. Il y a du travail à
fafaire dans l'ouest. Il y a une
vavague de fond qui se passe au
sesein du Parti conservateur, ue
vavague : n'importe qui Sofia
PoPoilievre. Ça pourrait aider
JeJean Charest à r rallier les
foforces, mêmeme au-delà d de cn
a a vu dans l'appui de ce matin.
- - C'est il va, on va assisterà
unun duel énorme entre les deux
grgrands quand de ce parti-là..
- - J'ai parlé à p plusieurs
coconservateurs qui mendient
auaujourd'hui : attachez votre
ceceinture, ça va êtrtre laid!
PiPierre Poilievre n'est pas das
dedes habitudes de dire qu'il ne
vava pas l'attaquer directement.
IlIl va attaquer très s fort et
MoMonsieur Charit va répondre ts
fofort. Ce qui peut dissuader Jn
ChCharest, c'est les règlgles da
cocourse. Si elle avait lieu en
jujuin, ce qui n'est pas
imimpossible, ça pouvait dire
ququ'il n'a pas le temps de faie
sisigner les cartes de membresÇa
dedeviendrait plus périlleux. Ms
auautrement, c'est sa dernièrere
chchance. Il le sait et elle a
vovoulu toute sa vie, il va y
alaller. Mais il faut avoir une
ororganisation qui n'est pas qul
avavait du temps où il était au
PaParti libéral. En 92, on ne
fafaisait pas campagne sur
InInstagram et TikTok. Il faut
vrvraiment qu'il s'habituait à
cecette nouvelle façon de fairee
lala politique.
- - Je lis et j'entends des gens
ququi disent qu'ils célibat, il
fafaut que d'autres candidats de
soson camp, plus centre, il y au
auaussi. S'il y a un deuxièmeme
totour, ce sont des voies qui
popourraient se reporter sur lu.
- - C'est le changement que l'on
asassiste dans les derniers jou.
OnOn voulait que tout le monde
s's'unifie d'emblée derrièrere n
ChCharest on se rend compte que
plplus il y aura d'organisations
ququi seront capables d'aller
chchercher des nouveaux membres,
c'c'est peut-êtrtre la meilleure
vovoie de passage.
- - Christian, on les votre